hello everyone
[音楽]
im 刑事富士もっと
アイムトータリーブライ
皆さんは自分がどんな人間か考えたことが
ありますか
あなたの長所は何ですか
短所はなんですか
私はどうかといえば人生の大部分自分の
短所ばかりを見ている人間でした
それを恥いつも隠そうとしていたんですね
でも
その後の人生のいろんな出会いが私を
大きく変えてくるだ
今日は皆さんに私のそんなヒストリーを
紹介したいと思います
まず私の小学校時代
私は頭の形田舎の農村で生まれたんですが
力外相という病気にかかったんです
地上で眼球注射を打たれたんですがもう
これが本当にいい旅たかっ
繰り返して繰り返し売っているうちに右目
は地左メールにずっと小さくなっちゃうし
クラスメイトには片目のジャックと言って
から買われる4
で修復がどんどん悪くなっていてでも私は
そのことを周りに知られたくなかったん
ですね
国語の教科書なんかは前の日に丸暗記して
次の日に授業では愛と手を挙げて当てて
もらってまぁそこまでして何とか自分の
見えないことを隠そうとしていたんです
でも修学になってもう学校行くことになり
ましたん
そこで
まあいよいよ杖をつくことになったんです
ね
もうこれが嫌で嫌でたまりませんでした
駅から学校までの10分間
毎日のように井戸端会議をしているおば
さんたちが若いのにかわいそう地でなんて
言うそんな笹駅声が聞こえてきました私は
そんな声を聞くと末を折りたたんでは
やっぱりここでも自分の盲目を隠そうとし
たんですね
そして展示
学校行って初めて天井触りましたがまぁ
これも本当にも呼べない
ああああ意味のないブツブツとしか思い
ませんでしたね
まあ自分は本も読めない勉強もできない
進学も就職も何もできない人間になっ
ちゃったと絶望のどん底にいました
そんなとき
一つの出会いがありました
大木先生という社会科の先生の出会いです
大木先生私に
藤本
目が見えなくても
耳と靴があれば英語教師になれるぞ
と言ってくれたんですね
もう私はこの言葉にすがりました
先生は私に nhk のラジオ講座を聞く
ように勧めてくださったんですが
今の朝ドラでは calm カーム
everybody っていうのが話題に
なってますよね私の時は基礎英語でしたで
もこれが本当に楽しかった
毎日その番組を録音してそうして聞いて
こいだして真似をしてこれが私と英語との
初めての出会いでした
越智先生が1年後に脳梗塞で亡くなられた
ことを考えるとあの本当に運命的な出会い
でしたん
二つ目の出会いはある盲目の青年ティム
ジョンソンとの出会いです
盲学校高等部の3年生の時私はアメリカ
ケンタッキー州立盲学校への留学の機会を
得ましたそこでではたのがティムジョンズ
彼は号買えない生き方をしていました
スポーツ板のベースツーリングに水泳の
チームで活躍していました音楽もバンド
トランペットにギターが弾けて学業も優秀
女の子にもモテモテまあとにかくまさに
人生をフルに
謳歌していたんですね
一方私はどうかといえば
ちょうど後頭部に入った時に両眼完全に
説明し自分は無能な人間になったという風
に思い込んでいました
皆さんは細胞とガーファンクルのボクサー
という曲をご存知でしょうか
古い曲だからご存知じゃないかもわから
ないですね
あー m the staff は望遠
ど my story 相談等
i am just アップはボーイ
僕はなんてかわいそうな少年なんだろうと
いう歌詞で始まるこの曲
私は自分のテーマソングのようにいつも
いつも歌っていましたそんな私に向かって
言うのは上屋を言わまあチョップはボーイ
ピンクポンセとぅ
と言って私を勇気づけてくれたまあそんな
留学時代でした
私はこうした経験を経て日本へ戻ってき
ました
某学校卒業が起き先生が示してくださった
通り教師になるべく
関西学院大学で進みました
そこでは盲導犬ざっきーとの出会いとか
いろんな出会いがあったんですがまぁ今日
はそれは割愛します
さて
1986年の春私は晴れて神戸市立葺合
高等学校の門をくぐりました
ます授業はどうかといえば
すべてティームティーチング
私と私を補助する教員2人が教室に入る
形式なんですね
まあそれはいいとして他の先生方が1週間
の担当15時間が当たり前の中私はたった
6時間だったんです
配属された部署の初会合では無ちょうど
先生がこう言いました
新任の先生の藤本先生です
みなさんよろしくお願いします
うわぁ
何もできないでしょうが
と紹介されて
私は一言も言い返すことができませんでし
た
教室に入ると40名という生徒の数に圧倒
され
苦手な展示を読み間違えては笑われ
そして生徒の名前も覚えられず散々でした
ベテランの補助教員の先生が前に行ってき
ては私の母児授業をするという始末でした
生徒からの信頼も完全に失ったと感じる
瞬間でした
そんな時私の心のよりどころとなることが
一つありました
スピーチコンテスト参加政党の指導です
私は当時 ess の二空港文をしてたん
ですがその主顧問の先生が私に言いました
コンテストの直前になったら僕は目ぇ瞑っ
て生徒の声を聞くようにしている
その方が政党が言葉に感情をどう込めて
いるかよく分かる
地元産はもしかしたら
僕よりもそれがずっと上手にできるかも
そう言ってくださったんですね
くしくもその年第1回の兵庫県英語
スピーチコンテストが開催されました
私の教員1年目がこの権大会の誕生の年
だったんですねそれから毎年毎年36年間
私は生徒と共にこの舞台を目指して
チャレンジするようになりました
というわけで希望の光が見つかって良かっ
たかなとは思ってたんですけど授業の方は
どうかというとこちらの方は何の進展も
ありません
授業は6時間のまま
しかも他にも全然私に任されるような仕事
はありませんでした
周りから全く期待されていないなっていう
のをつくづく感じたんですね
それを感じた時に私は首位の先生に対して
あの心閉じてしまいました
できないこともあるはずなのにもう迫
サポートなんかなしにやってやろうなんか
やけくそになっちゃったんですね
テストの採点も家族にやってもらったり
補助教員に対しても授業は一人でできる
から大丈夫だよと言い放ってみたり
まぁしかしそういうのってうまくいくわけ
がないですよね
ただ期待されてないからがんばらなくても
ええやろ
自暴自気になったんです
5年10年15年
長い年月が過ぎていきました
そこで訪れたのが2005年
私にとってはちょっとした転換期です
文科省が a 5人
英語の使える日本人の育成プログラムと
いうのを始めたんですねそして葺合高校が
スーパー english
language ハイスクをに認定され
ました
少人数のクラスが導入されることになり
英語教員の風が足りなくなったんですね
ある教会のこと
あー先生方
ちょっとこの事業を担当してくれる人い
ませんか
呼び掛けないと
私は心の中で葛藤しました等賞銅賞
ここで声出したらもしかした授業が増える
かもしれない同省同省でモナーゼしないな
夫婦地元やります
一言声を出すことができたんです
声を上げたこの一言のおかげで6時間が8
時間になった2時間増えたんです実に20
年かかってやっと2時間増えたんです
こんなに長いとし次はかかったんですよ
それはひとえに私に勇気がなかったから
私の盲目に向き合う勇気がなかったから
です
何ができ何ができないか
それに向き合う勇気がなかったんですね
できない部分のサポートさえあれば自分に
は授業ができる
そう周囲に心を開いて使えるを伝えること
ができませんでした
皆さん映画のバークトゥザフューチャー
ご存知だと思いますがあそこに出てくる
タイムバスティンがもしここにあれば私は
1986年に立ち返って当時の自分にこう
語りかけるでしょう
ページ
ギャだ u cars
次はブラインドです
ギャ台はタレスオープンやはーい
キューピープアランディ
こうして私は
周りの方たちとコラボをしながらの授業を
始めるようになりました
ではまあ2020年の今1月ですよね今
どんな感じで授業をしているかというのを
ちょっと紹介させていただきます
私とパートナーズ先生一緒にこう教室に
入ってきます
制度に向かって曇りに指バーンと私は生徒
に話しかけそして問いかけ
そして以前は苦手だった教科書の音読しろ
こういう口で出来る部分を私が担当する
ようになりました
もう一人のパートナーの先生は例えば黒板
に銃を書いたり政党のノートをチェックし
たり
政党の活動状況を私に報告してくれたり
メドをつかう部分っていうのを担当して
くれるようになったんですね2人の
チームワークというので授業が進めるよう
になったわけです
おかげで
昔は6時間しか教えられなかったのが今で
は16時間
他の先生と同じだけの忙しさを味わえる
ようになりました
放課後のスピーチ指導でもやはりこの
コラボが大切です
日本人教員とともに正答している
ネイティブの先生を lt
assistant language
teacher
と言いますが鋭利 t の先生が例えば
政党の英語の発音やそして文法をチェック
するジェスチャーをチェックする私の方は
生徒が言葉にどう感情を込めているかそこ
に集中することができる
私と alt のコラボこれによって
電話最終目標が県大会だった生徒がまあ今
では県から建機近畿から全国へとどんどん
羽ばたいていけるようになりました
スピーチと同様に私が情熱を傾けることに
なるディベート活動
まあこちらは私と alt とそれから生
とのコラボが大切ですね
ディベートには試合の勝ち負けがつきもの
です
試合に勝って生徒が喜べば私も喜ぶ試合に
負けて生徒が波でを流せば私も一緒に泣き
ます
このな気はないというのがやっぱり
リベートの素晴らしさですよね
ここに一冊の本があります
これは2年前にディベートのメンバーが私
にプレゼントしてくれた10時の色紙です
これですね
当時関わっていた40名の生徒が一人一人
私にメッセージを展示で支えてくれました
これ実は私ね今の家の神棚にいつもで飾っ
ているんですね朝になったらこの大が拝ん
でるんですねかってねパーンとやってです
ね拝んでるんですよまあそれだけ私にとっ
てはこの展示の指摘してが自分の何よりの
宝物なんですね
まあこうして私は葺合高校での36年間を
終えました
私は今年から再雇用の1年目に入ってい
ます
でも今の私はやっぱり授業もっと改善し
なきゃという気持ちになりまして昨年から
神戸外大の大学院で英語教授法を学んでい
ますそこでもまたボランティアの学生や
一緒に学んでいる先生たちとのコラボが
大切になっています
さて最後にみなさんにひとつお聞きしたい
ことがあります
皆さんはこれから社会を釣っ作って行か
れる方ですよね
社会の中でもし皆さんが障害を持ってる人
と出会ったときにどんな行動を取られる
でしょうか
街の中であるいは職場で皆さんの同僚とし
てい
で実は私同じ質問を昨年の春
葺合高校の3年生400名に対してこの
同じ質問をしてみました
その質問に対する生徒のコメントを最後に
紹介して終わりたいと思います
まずこれは k さんのコメントです
これから駅のホームや歩道で困っている人
を見かけたらすぐに駆けつけたい助けたい
です
困っている人の前に立って引っ張っていき
ます
なかなか力強いメッセージですね
この計算の続きです
今日は一人一人違うんだということを学び
ましただからこそ
障害のあるなしに関わらず一人一人を素直
に受け入れる受け入れられるようになり
たい
そう思うようになりました
2人目はこれ t さんです t さんの
コメントです
先生どうであって
目が見えないだけで大変な人生だって
思い込むのは間違っていると気づきました
先生が英語スラスラ話しているのを聞くと
人生において
ハンディがあったとしても誰でもこんな
ふうに輝けるんだと思うことができるよう
になりました
私が働き始めたときに他の誰も私に仕事を
任せてくれなかったそんな時に
私の強みを見つけ
スピーチを勧めてくださったそんな先生が
いました
皆さんはこれからどんな行動を取られる
でしょうか
アーティーアンドエスピー子
i ああきっと明日級だ西武クエッション
r 明日 purity ring of
mice b
はディーズ安くないです
はいずれはウィークです
b ハーブサーフィンいうフィギュア発車
六堂
姫な bu wiki です
インステップアクセっていう縁でアピス a
2前方ジャンパーと ob は
アイデンティティ
セレブ0
uu
1009乗松
ありがとうございましたーーー